my daughter did not do this my son we
nicknamed him button boy when he was a
kid because he was obsessed with tech
and he was constantly if he saw anyone's
phone around or any device he would grab
it and start pushing buttons and he
intuitively or magically would always do
something change the time and he wasn't
at the earliest stage he was doing that
and so we called him button boy and in a
lot of the photographs we have of him as
a kid he's always holding a device
anything that has a button he'd find
like a cheap plastic almost disposable
digital watch on the beach and just hang
on to it for months oh my God and keep
pushing the buttons did they have busy
boards back then because we just got one
for Glenn and it's a wood board with
like 20 switches and lights that they
just turn on and off and it's amazing I
just sit there and play with it oh
that's cool yeah it is I have a couple
toys of the boys I'm obsessed with like
what like these stacking cups I need to
have all nine of them it's very
important they'll be coming to me for
attention and I'll just shove them aside
to look for these stacking cups what do
you mean stacking they're just I don't
know there's just I have an obsession
right now with just keeping this
specific toy intact and I don't know why
wait you have the obsession or they do I
do wait you're playing with a child's
toy yeah but Matt
toy yeah but mine's a busy board yeah
that's a busy board you're just you're
just stacking cups that's called
cleaning up in the
kitchens
toy they have it's called laundry and
hamper
what else are you obsessed with playing
my mom is obsessed with this one Turtle
toy where you put the shapes in there
and she needs to make sure all the
pieces are there you know I get the
sense that you and your mom and probably
your dad and your husband are busy
playing with children's toys yeah well
Mikey and Shirley are just wandering the
highway yeah on foot
you're like look I stacked them
you know what my son's button Obsession
this is true story uh we were in
Washington for some event I forget what
it was and we got to have a tour of the
White House that they you know and they
were giving us some special stuff like
oh you can go here you can go there I
think I had done the White House
corresponds dinner it might have been uh
is it Christmas in Washington I don't
know if I can't remember what it was it
was one of those events where I'm in
Washington and
so I'm there and I'm with my producer
Jeff Ross So Liz was with us and my
daughter was with us and and my son and
he's really young at the time and at one
point they took us downstairs and they
have this this special room and I think
it's like with the iconic picture of
when they got Bin Laden oh yeah they
showed us those rooms I don't think we
were in that room but we were in the
there's a mirror image room right next
to it and they were showing us that room
this is like a situation room like a
situation room and they said yeah you
can take a look at this room and there's
a button in the room and so my son just
leans over and hits the button and
suddenly I was just thinking like maybe
you shouldn't push that because there's
a button in the middle of the situation
where my son just leans forward and hits
it and very quickly a door opens up and
a guy leans in and said everything okay
in here and we were like yeah
everything's fine what and he went oh
the like we need someone to come in here
button was just pushed and my son was
like panicked for a second that he had
done something wrong
and I said no you did the right thing
you saw a button in the White House
Situation Room no no that's the wrong
and you hit it that was not the right
well if he didn't I was going to do it
what no you should know better you're
the adult there was a half second where
I thought he had launched a missile yeah
yeah but would it be that easy
apparently they're just all over the
place the buttons to launch the missiles
yes definitely and you know what they
really they look just like light
switches yeah and you know what they
also on a busy board stupidly they put
them right next to the elevator
and for the missile to go the missile to
if you want to fire a missile up into
the atmosphere at another country it's
just a little triangle pointing up yeah
and if you want to fire a torpedo
there's one just going down yeah okay
yeah no true story true it's a true
story okay you two say it they also have
a bunch over near uh the snack machine
by the vending machine yeah there's a
little there's buttons there too I think
it's A7 is either Sun Chips or you
decimate some part of Turkey
no but uh all joking aside I I do think
it's quite a complicated process to
launch a missile it must be at least I'm
kind of hoping it is I am oh God you
know yeah what's this button do oh no
okay what what would it do in here well
what button you just created another
podcast oh no that's how easy it is to
create a podcast
it's called Jawbone
with skaz and Millie skaz and Millie
just chew the fat from their basement in
Santa Clarita jaw bonan available
wherever you get your podcasts